wieso zum nächsten
Tagesordnungspunkt das dominierende
Thema im Bundestag in dieser Woche das
war tatsächlich und ist tatsächlich die
steigenden Energiepreise und die
Belastungen für Verbraucher aber auch
für Unternehmen
das belastet viele Haushalte in
Deutschland an einer Stelle soll es für
Mieter und MieterInnen nun vor allem
Entlastung geben der Bundestag berät
nämlich jetzt in diesem nächsten
Tagesordnungspunkt über den Entwurf des
sogenannten
Kohlendioxid Kosten
aufteilungsgesetzes so heißt es wirklich
der Entwurf der sieht nämlich vor dass
ich Mieter und Vermieterseite die CO2
Kosten bei den Heizkosten künftig teilen
sollen es gibt ein Stufenmodell dazu
werden wir einiges noch in der
Aussprache
erfahren das ist die erste Lesung zu
diesem Gesetzentwurf und die erste
Rednerin kommt aus den Reihen der
Bundesregierung das ist Kanzel
kiesel-tepe für die SPD die
Parlamentarische Staatssekretärin im
baumministerium
Klimaschutz im Gebäudebereich ist nicht
nur eine technische Frage sondern sie
ist zuallererst eine soziale Frage und
wie diese große Aufgabe zu lösen ist
zeigt das Kohlendioxid Kosten
aufteilungsgesetz
bisher tragen die Mieterinnen und Mieter
den CO2-Preis alleine dass das nicht so
bleiben kann haben wir im
Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart hier räumen
wir ein Konstruktionsfehler ab den die
Union in der letzten Legislatur
verschuldet hat
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen in der
Ampel haben wir vereinbart ein
Stufenmodell für die Umlage des
co2-preises einzuführen eine faire
Lösung zu finden war viel Arbeit vielen
Dank an alle Beteiligten Ampel
Ressourcen
wir haben den Zeitplan eingehalten wir
haben am 25 Mai diesen Jahres dieses
Gesetz in der Bundesregierung
beschlossen den wir heute hier in erster
Lesung beraten
mit dem vorgesehenen Stufenmodell werden
einerseits Mieterinnen und Mieter
entlastet und weiterhin zu sparsamen
Heizverhalten angereizt auf der anderen
Seite gilt für Vermieterinnen und
Vermieter
Anreize zu schaffen in Energieeffizienz
ihrer Gebäude zu investieren und damit
kann die seit 2021 erhobene CO2-Preis
bei Wärme endlich seine klimapolitische
Lenkungswirkung auch entfalten liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
die Wirkung wird kurzfristig durch die
Folgen des völkerrechtswidrigen
angriffskriegs Russlands überdeckt
werden die Krise hat massive
Auswirkungen auf unsere
Energieversorgung und die Energiekosten
doch wir müssen langfristig denken wir
dürfen gar nicht erst erpressbar sein
von Despoten wie Putin auch hierfür
liefert das Gesetz einen Beitrag
mit dem
co2-kostenaufteilungsgesetz wollen wir
eine faire Aufteilung der Kosten
zwischen mietenden und vermietenden
schaffen die Verantwortung darf nicht
einseitig auf den Schultern der
Mieterinnen und Mieter abgeladen werden
das Stufenmodell für Wohngebäude knüpft
an den CO2-Ausstoß des vermieteten
Gebäudes an je niedriger die
energetische Qualität eines Gebäudes ist
umso größer ist der Anteil der
Vermieterin bzw das Vermieters und umso
kleiner ist der Anteil der Mieterinnen
und Mieter an den co2-
die Umsetzung kann ohne größeren Aufwand
im Rahmen der Heizkostenabrechnung
erfolgen Vermieterinnen und Vermieter
werden mit der brennstoffrechnung alle
für die Berechnung erforderlichen Daten
an die Hand gegeben es ist eine
bürokratiearme Lösung für einen sehr
komplexen Sachverhalt
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen das
Gesetz soll am ersten Januar 2023 in
Kraft treten daran halten wir fest
gleichzeitig war uns aber auch klar in
der aktuellen Situation sind weitere
Energiepreissteigerungen zu verhindern
wir wollen auch kein Öl ins Feuer gießen
und deshalb haben wir im dritten
Entlastungspaket die Anhebung des
co2-preises verschoben
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen darüber
hinaus bringen wir weitere Maßnahmen zur
Entlastung bei den Heizungs Heizkosten
bei den Heizkosten auf den Weg wir
zahlen einen zweiten Heizkostenzuschuss
und führen in Rekordzeit eine
wohngeldreform mit historischem Maßstab
durch
[Applaus]
wir wollen nämlich den Menschen mit
kleinen und mittleren Einkommen schnell
und zielgenau unterstützen denn sie sind
es die besonders stark von den
steigenden Energiepreisen betroffen sind
und da möchten wir unterstützend
eingreifen vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
ja daher hat die Bundesregierung hier
diesen Gesetzentwurf vorgelegt seitdem
ersten Januar 2021 wird ja in
Deutschland ein CO2-Preis fällig
beispielsweise auf Heizöl erdgasben oder
Diesel dadurch erhöhen sich auch die
Energiekosten für Mieter nach der
aktuellen Rechtslage können die
Heizkosten inklusive der darin
enthaltenen CO2 kosten ja komplett auf
die Mieter umgelegt werden das soll sich
ändern
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
ich will das sperrige Wort gar nicht
verwenden es soll eine faire Aufteilung
der
co2-kosten seine so wie es uns die Ampel
glauben machen aber was heißt von fair
und gerecht in diesem Zusammenhang ich
glaube an dieser Stelle müssen Sie Ihren
Gesetzentwurf selber noch mal genau
lesen man sollte nicht damit beginnen
Mieterinnen und Mieter gegen Vermieter
auszuspielen denn es gibt nicht die eine
übermächtige Seite und es gibt nicht den
einen den Guten und den anderen den
bösen ich erlaube mir zu darauf hin zu
wie Eisen dass zwei Drittel der
Mietwohnungen in privater Hand kleiner
Vermieter sind die ihren bürokratischen
Wahnsinn jetzt bearbeiten müssen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
wir brauchen keine ideologische Lösung
sondern eine sachgerechte klimagerechte
und bezahlbare und da zeigt sich
natürlich schon der Konstruktionsfehler
dieses Gesetzentwurfes sind wir heute in
der ersten Lesung diskutieren denn das
Gesetz orientiert sich eben nicht daran
wie gut oder schlecht der energetische
Standards des Gebäudes ist sondern daran
wie viel tatsächlich geheizt wird also
wie viel CO2 ausgestoßen wird wird mehr
geheizt auch bei offenem Fenster
übernimmt der Vermieter den höheren
Anteil an den co2-kosten da fehlt die
Anreizwirkung die Sie gerade behauptet
haben die können wir in diesem
Gesetzentwurf tatsächlich nicht erkennen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
die Pflicht zur energetischen Sanierung
für den Vermieter die müssen Sie
natürlich auch entsprechend entlohnen da
müssen sie mit investieren aber genau
die ganzen Förderprogramme haben sie
dieses Jahr entweder gekürzt oder
gestrichen oder Sie haben es angeblich
neu aufgesetzt und darauf warten wir
heute noch liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen das ist keine verlässliche
Politik sowohl für Vermieter und
Vermieterinnen wie für Mieter so schafft
man keinen Wohnraum so schafft man kein
klimagerechtes bauen so schafft man kein
Zuhause für die Menschen
wie wie wollen Sie denn wie wollen Sie
denn mit großen Familien umgehen mit
alten Menschen umgehen die definitiv
einen höheren Wärmebedarf haben da wird
sich der Vermieter überlegen nämlich den
Einpersonenhaushalt oder die große
Familie das sind doch die Dinge das was
sie hier vorgelegt haben Frau
Staatssekretärin das ist nicht gerecht
und fair nein das ist unsozial
kontraproduktiv gegenüber Familien und
älteren Menschen das ist eigentlich
genau das was sie versprochen haben
nicht liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen und
dann kommt ein extrem
kompliziertes 10 stufen-modell über die
brennstoffabrechnung und den Ausweis des
abrechnungsverfahrens ein
gruppierungsstufen müssen dann ermittelt
werden natürlich am Ende mit der
Heizkostenabrechnung aber schauen Sie
sich doch heute schon eine
Heizkostenabrechnung an dann kommen zehn
Stufen dazu und dann machen wir auch
noch ein
heizkostenabrechnungsbrennstoffverfahren
am besten noch eine Verordnung dazu dann
wird es richtig gut dann haben wir
Bürokratie pur und keine wirkliche
Anreizwirkung für alle Parteien in einem
Mietverhältnis das ist das ist
Bürokratie und das ist nicht Qualität
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen und da
muss ich sie von der FDP von fragen wir
haben da mal gelesen
bürokratisieren wir das Land liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der FDP haben
sie getönt das was Sie jetzt tun ist
hyperbürokratisieren sie das Land sie
machen es schlechter nicht besser damit
sie haben offensichtliche Schwächen in
dem Entwurf das haben sogar ihre Länder
Bauminister schon festgestellt schauen
Sie sich mal an was die Länderminister
ihnen so auf den Weg geben lesen bildet
da kann ich Ihnen wirklich nur dazu
raten wir müssen Vermieter auch dabei
unterstützen zu sanieren
energetisch entsprechend aufzurüsten
Klimaschutz geht nicht mit Federstrich
und Gesetz
Klimaschutz geht nur mit Investitionen
und genau da haben sie seit Januar
grünlich versagt liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
was sie hier machen ist keine Politik
für bezahlbaren Wohnraum für 400.000
Wohnungen es ist keine Politik für
klimagerechtes bauen es ist ideologische
Umverteilung es ist der Gegner das
Gegenteil von Nachhaltigkeit zum Glück
gibt es parlamentarische Beratungen
danke schön
Ulrich lange war das für die
cdu/csu-fraktion ja eigentlich sollte
schon in der vergangenen Legislatur der
CO2-Preis auf Heizkosten zwischen
Mietern und Vermietern aufgeteilt werden
allerdings hatte die Union damals in der
Bundesregierung dies nicht mitgetragen
ich habe angeschaltet ich quatschen
bisschen vor mich hin
sie hören zu
die nächste Rednerin ist Hanna
Steinmüller für Bündnis 90 die Grünen
und die
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin Katrin Göring
Eckert leitet jetzt diese Sitzung ruft
die nächste Rednerin auf Hanna
Steinmüller für die Grünen
Kollegen Herr Lange sie
[Applaus]
sind zum Beispiel
gedächtnisstimme es war ihre Koalition
die dafür gesorgt hat sie ist die
Belastung des co2-preises momentan zu
100% von den Mieterinnen und Mietern
getragen werden wo das fair ist wo das
energetische Sanierung Anreizen soll mir
ist es schleierhaft und ich frage mich
was ihre konkreten Vorschläge sind die
sind sie leider schuldig geblieben
unser Ziel ist klar wir wollen mehr
energetische Sanierung denn je besser
das Haus saniert ist desto niedriger ist
der Energieverbrauch und damit sind
Mieterinnen und Mieter am Ende auch
unabhängiger von steigenden Preisen
deswegen ist es ein wichtiger Maßnahme
dass wir energetische Sanierung Anreizen
dabei nehmen wir Vermieterinnen und
Vermieter in die Pflicht das stimmt
niemand zwingt ein Vermieterin oder ein
Vermieter dass das Haus schlecht saniert
bleibt das kann man ändern dafür gibt es
fördermelte die wurden auch nicht
gestrichen das was schrittzig war ist
die Neubauförderung Sanierung ist immer
durchfinanziert und Sie können natürlich
weiter vor sich hin Murmeln aber Sie
sollten schon die Realitäten annehmen
unser Ziel ist dass es zu energetischen
Sanierung gibt von daher der Appell
nutzen Sie die Förderung des Klima- und
die MieterInnen danken Ihnen nun läuft
der Gesetze das gibt Beratung zum
Gesetzentwurf schon es gibt aus unserer
Sicht doch einige offene Fragen aber
dafür gibt es ja die Beratungen zum
einen bleibt das Thema der
Harmonisierung der Stufen das heißt die
Gleichbehandlung der besten und der
schlechtesten Häuser wir fordern einen
Online-Rechner damit es für die
Kleinvermieter die sie ja immer erwähnen
einfacher ist nachzurechnen und für die
Mieterinnen und Mieter auch transparent
ist wie die Kosten zusammenkommen wir
fordern und da besteht aber auch schon
Einigkeit eine Verlängerung der Fristen
für die selbstversorge auch die haben
sie erwähnt das haben wir bereits gelöst
und wir müssen noch mal diskutieren über
Ausnahmen bei Milieu Schutz und beim
Denkmalschutz mit
ja deswegen gibt es ja gesetzliche
Beratungen wäre ja langweilig wenn man
immer alles durchnicken müsste also mit
dem Gesetzentwurf bringen wir
Klimaschutz und mieterinnenschutz
zusammen und ich freue mich auf die
weiteren Beratung vielen Dank
Mark Bernhard spricht für die
afd-fraktion
[Musik]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
bevor man eine Steuer einführt sollte
man erst mal prüfen ob die Menschen sie
überhaupt bezahlen können
unzählige Male habe ich hier im
Deutschen Bundestag vor der Einführung
der CO2-Steuer darauf hingewiesen dass
viele Millionen Menschen die Steuer eben
nicht bezahlen können und seitdem sind
die Mieten
warum sind wir denn sonst hier wenn Sie
sie alle bezahlen könnten dann werden
wir nicht hier ja also sie können sie
offensichtlich nicht mit Zahlen und
seitdem sind die Mieten die Heizkosten
die Stromkosten die Lebensmittelkosten
die Spritpreise immens gestiegen im
letzten Jahr mussten bereits 7,4
Millionen Menschen in ihren Wohnungen
frieren 400.000 Haushalte wurde durch
Strom abgestellt um mehr als 60 Prozent
der Menschen können keinen einzigen
Patienten mehr für die Jahresabrechnung
der Nebenkosten zurücklegen die wissen
also heute schon dass im Januar die
Nachzahlung gar nicht bezahlen können
anscheinend haben sie jetzt auch gemerkt
dass ihre Politik mit ihrer verkorksten
Energiewende die Mittelschicht direkt in
den Bankrott treibt und jetzt wollen sie
jetzt wollen sie mit ihrem Kohlendioxid
Kosten aufteilungsgesetz welcher
sprachakrobat hat sich eigentlich dieses
Wort Ungetüm ausgedacht wahrscheinlich
wollen sie den Menschen vorgeeignen
vorgaukeln dass sie mit diesem Gesetz
sie tatsächlich entlasten wollten bei
der CO2-Steuer bei tatsächlich machen
sie doch nur eins sie verschieben die
Belastung von einer Bevölkerungsgruppe
auf die andere von den Mietern zu den
Vermietern von denen über 60 Prozent
Kleinvermieter sind die allermeisten
über 60 Jahre alt und die besseren sich
durch Miete ihre Rente auf diese
Menschen die in der Regel über 40 Jahre
lang gearbeitet haben ihre Steuern
bezahlt haben Sozialabgaben geleistet
haben und damit unser Land am Laufen
gehalten haben bestrafen sie jetzt mit
diesem Gesetz auch noch dafür dass Ihre
Ersparnisse dafür verwendet haben um den
dringend benötigten Wohnraum in unserem
Land zu schaffen sie zwingen mit diesem
Gesetz diese Kleinvermieter dazu
entweder Wohnungen gar nicht mehr zu
vermieten bei Kosten und bürokratische
Aufwand den Nutzen übersteigen oder sie
nötigen diese Menschen die Kaltmiete zu
erhöhen weil niemand der Wohnungen zur
Verfügung stellt am Ende auch noch
draufzahlen kann sie verschlimmern also
mit diesem Gesetz die Situation für die
Menschen weiter da ist unweigerlich dazu
führen wird dass es weniger Wohnungen
zur Verfügung stehen und sich die Mieten
weiter erhöhen dabei könnte es doch so
einfach sein
die völlig vermurkste Energiewende
beenden und einfach und das einfach so
machen wie unsere europäischen Nachbarn
durch die Senkung von Steuern und
Abgaben wie beispielsweise Polen Italien
Belgien Holland Frankreich Spanien und
so weiter wir fordern daher erstens die
Mehrwertsteuer auf Energie auf null
senken zweitens die Aktiven
Kernkraftwerke weiterlaufen lassen und
die drei vor kurzem abgeschalteten
wieder einschalten allein diese einzige
Maßnahme würde dafür sorgen dass der
Strompreis sich sofort halbieren würde
und ein Blackout in diesem Winter sicher
verhindert werden würde und drittens und
vor allem die CO2-Steuer einfach
komplett abschaffen dann könnten wir uns
nämlich diesen ganzen Unsinn heute
sparen liebe Freunde ja könnten wir
hören Sie endlich auf die Menschen mit
Waschlappen und duschempfehlungen oder
mit Taschenspieler Tricks wie diesem
Gesetz für dumm zu verkaufen sorgen Sie
dafür dass die Menschen endlich wirklich
entlastet werden im Winter nicht frieren
und eben nicht im Dunkeln setzen müssen
der Kollege Daniel Fürst spricht jetzt
für die FDP-Fraktion und er Versprecher
für Bau- und Wohnungspolitik der
Liberalen
frau Präsidentin werte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
also das bei der AFD nicht mal die
eigene Fraktion klatscht das kann ich
nachvollziehen die sind wahrscheinlich
allen Moskau ich verstehe ja die
Skandalisierung der Union ich verstehe
es ja weil wir haben jetzt ein Gesetz
vorgelegt dass man
beschreiben kann als was lange währt
wird endlich gut und deswegen verstehe
ich ja dass ihr da jetzt einen ein
Skandalisierung betreibt weil es nicht
hinbekommen habt ich bin jetzt an dem
Punkt übrigens nicht wieder bei 16 Jahre
Union das ich werde es nicht wieder
machen weil tatsächlich an dem Punkt
muss ich euch in einer Stelle recht
geben an einer Stelle muss ich euch
Recht geben dass ihr 50/50 letzte
Legislatur verhindert habt macht dieses
Gesetz erst möglich weil 50 50 wäre
wirklich ungerecht gewesen genauso wie
100 0 ungerecht ist es haben im
Gebäudebestand sowohl der Eigentümer als
auch der Nutzer die Möglichkeit Energie
zu sparen und dass wir Energie sparen
Anreizen durch einen Preis den wir dann
aufteilen ist goldrichtig deswegen wäre
ich nie in die auf die Idee gekommen die
CO2-Preis zu in Frage zu stellen der
übrigens keine Steuer ist aber dass der
AFD zu erklären dafür reicht die Zeit
nicht weil das wird einfach in Jahren
nicht funktioniert aber dass wir dass
wir Anreize setzen dass der Eigentümer
investiert dass wir Anreize setzen dass
der Nutzer spart das ist doch
goldrichtig es ist notwendig und 1000
ich weiß weil Kollege lange fahre ich
zum Kollege lukschachtsfrei ist 100 0
nur einer von zwei Parteien zahlt alles
überwoll ich obwohl er nicht alles
beeinflussen kann deshalb finde auch ich
als freie Demokrat als ungerecht was
gerecht ist ist tatsächlich dieses
Gesetz nämlich
wenn sich ja lange aufregt dass ich es
auf den Verbrauch konzentriert also auf
die tatsächliche emittierte Menge CO2
dann ist das ein längst überfälliger
Schritt in die richtige Richtung möchte
nur erinnern an die letzte
Legislaturperiode haben wir darüber
diskutiert hier im Deutschen Bundestag
die deutsche Volkswirtschaft hat 395
Milliarden Euro in den letzten 12 Jahren
in den energetische Gebäudesanierung
investiert weil wir das mittelbar über
Effizienzen über
Energieausweise gemacht haben war der
Effekt nahezu null trotz gigantische
Investitionen brauchen haben wir die
Emissionen nicht senken können und das
jetzt endlich umzustellen auf die
tatsächliche Emission CO2 ist ein längst
überfälliger Schritt und deshalb mit
Bürokratie nichts zu tun
zum anderen
ich hatte ich hatte auch erst schon die
Vorstellung wir können es am Gebäude
Energieausweis machen
der Gebäudeenergieausweis ist verbreitet
er ist akzeptiert aber dann hättet ihr
den auch rechtssicher ausgestalten
müssen und das kriegen wir in der
Geschwindigkeit nicht hin der ist
schlichtweg nicht rechtliche
ausgeschaltet und deswegen nehmen wir
den Mittel über die tatsächliche
Emission CO2 und auch das ist wichtig
was ebenso wichtig ist und was auch
weder ihre Idee von alles zahlen die
Mieterinnen und Mieter noch die Idee
50/50 nicht adressiert die
Ausdifferenzierung auf zehn Stufen
reizt auch kleine Investitionen im
Bestand an weil was nämlich tatsächlich
nicht funktioniert von jedem zu erwarten
dass er sofort alles durchsaniert das
geht nicht also haben wir ein System
gewählt indem man durch einfache
Maßnahmen indem man durch überschaubare
Investitionen jetzt sage ich wieder mein
Lieblingsthema zum Beispiel smarte
thermotathermostat oder Smart Home
Technik die nur wenige tausend Euro
kostet nicht gleich mehrere 10.000 Euro
sich verbessert in der Stufe und genau
diesen Anreiz müssen wir endlich setzen
weil ich weiß nicht ob sie ihn
aufgefallen ist Werte Kollegin und
Kollegen von der Union die Zeit im
Gebäudebestand CO2 zu reduzieren die
läuft uns davon
gleichzeitig haben wir in Mangel an
Fachkräften an Arbeitskräften wir haben
Mangel an Material wir Mangel an
genehmigungskapazitäten deswegen ist es
wichtig dass wir schnelle kleine
Investitionen Anreizen und genau dieses
macht dieses Gesetz und deswegen ist es
auch fair und richtig
was ich ebenfalls für wichtig halte da
müssen wir natürlich noch mal drüber
diskutieren Struktur Gesetz sie kennen
das alles ich habe zwar genommen dass
der luftag gar nicht mitdiskutieren will
weil er sagt wir diskutieren zu viel
aber fein wir müssen noch mal überlegen
ob wir nicht alternative Brennstoffe
alternative Brennstoffe die CO2 arms in
CO2 frei sind wirklich nicht besser
berücksichtigen wollen in diesem Gesetz
weil im Endeffekt geht es um den
CO2-Ausstoß im Bestand und da sind
alternative Brennstoffe tatsächlich in
Punkt da müssen wir noch mal drüber
diskutieren Kollegin Steinmüller hat
völlig zu Recht angemerkt dass in diesem
Gesetz zwar mal die Bereiche in denen
ich nicht aktiv werden kann als
Eigentümer Milieu Schutzgebiet unter
gewissen Voraussetzungen
es ist Schutz der der Gebäude
Denkmalschutz der Gebäude das in diesen
Bereichen das Gesetz erstmal mit
Ausnahmen versehen ist und das halte ich
für richtig großes Thema haben wir noch
bei den Nichtwohngebäuden und da ich
weiß nicht liebe Union wenn ihr von der
Skandalisierung runterkommt bringt er
Vorschläge das bringt Vorschläge ich bin
ja wirklich bereit und offen zuzuhören
aber es sich erstmal darüber aufzuregen
dass der Name zu kompliziert ist das
zeigt natürlich schon ein bisschen dass
man relativ wenig weiteres hat in dem
Sinne schließlich frau Präsidentin
vielen Dank für die Debatte das wird ein
gutes Gesetz ist vielleicht eine
Unfairness aus und es beschleunigt die
Sanierung im Bestand und das ist
dringend notwendig
sagt hier Daniel
e für die
FDP-Fraktion dann hören wir mal wie die
Bewertung der Linken ausfällt für die
Linke spricht jetzt gesehene Lötsch
deren stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren mit diesem Gesetz
sollen die Menschen zu wörtlich
Energieeinsparungen angereizt werden ich
frage sie in welcher Realität leben Sie
denn eigentlich die Menschen sparen doch
jetzt schon wo sie können weil sie ihre
Rechnung nicht mehr bezahlen können das
müssen Sie doch mal zur Kenntnis nehmen
sie treiben mit ihrer Politik die
Menschen in die Armut die Aussetzung bzw
die Verschiebung des co2-preises ist
eben keine Lösung ich bin der Auffassung
wir müssen diese CO2-Preise endlich
abschaffen die
marktgläubige Klimapolitik ist nämlich
sozial ungerecht sie trifft immer die
Menschen am härtesten die für wenig Geld
jeden Tag arbeiten gehen müssen oder gar
keine bezahlte Arbeit haben daran wird
eine echte Klimawende scheitern die
Klimakrise ist nur dann wenn die
verteilungskrise gelöst wird doch eine
Vermögenssteuer steht zum Beispiel immer
schön in den Wahlprogrammen von SPD und
Grünen nur nicht in den
Koalitionsvereinbarungen und da ist doch
was faul da müsste sich was ändern meine
Damen und Herren
die Bundesregierung will nun das Mieter
und Vermieter Energiesparen bisher
mussten das ist ja schon dargestellt
werden die Mieter den CO2-Preis zu 100
Prozent zahlen in ihrem
Koalitionsvertrag haben sich
verpflichtet diesen Preis helftig also
fifty-fifty zwischen Mietern und
Vermietern aufzuteilen das wird aber mit
diesem Gesetzesentwurf nicht passieren
der Berliner Mieterverein rechnet sogar
damit dass vier von fünf Haushalten mehr
als 50 Prozent des co2-preises zahlen
müssen und das ist schwer ungerecht
meine Damen und Herren der Mieterbund
rechnet vor dass die CO2-Abgabe 2022 und
67 Euro für Gas und achtundneunzig Euro
für Heizöl im Jahr für eine Wohnung
ausmacht und bis 2025 soll der Preis für
Gas auf 125 Euro und für Öl auf 180 Euro
steigen in Anbetracht der explodierenden
Krise der explodierenden Preise ist das
für viele Menschen nichts anderes als
eine offene und dem stellen wir uns
entgegen meine Damen und Herren
sie wollen mit dem CO2-Preis ein
finanziellen Anreiz zum Energiesparen
schaffen das Problem ist dass die
Mieterinnen und Mieter überhaupt keinen
Einfluss darauf haben ob die Vermieter
ihr Haus energetisch sanieren oder nicht
und dieses Modell trifft besonders arme
Menschen die in schlecht sanierten
Häusern wohnen und das in höchstem Maße
ungerecht und das können wir nicht
hinnehmen
meine Damen und Herren wir fordern
unserem Antrag dass der CO2-Preis zu 100
Prozent von den Vermietern zu tragen ist
ich sagte ja wir wollen den CO2-Preis
abschaffen und nur so schaffen wir einen
starken finanziellen Anreiz für die
energetische Sanierung von Wohnhäusern
natürlich wissen wir dass es viele
Kleinvermieter gibt wir wollen dass die
Kleinvermieter durch einen härtefallfond
entlastet werden das wäre der richtige
Weg das wäre der Gerechte Weg dafür
kämpfen wir vielen Dank
hier für die Linksfraktion jetzt hören
wir für die Sozialdemokraten noch mal
einen Redner Martin diedenhoven wird es
sein
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen kennen Sie
eigentlich Gernot Hassknecht sie wissen
schon der heute show Comedian der sich
in einer Lautstärke über die Politik
aufregt dass man seinen Fernseher
eigentlich einige Stufen leiser drehen
muss außer man will Stress mit den
Nachbarn riskieren ein bisschen so wie
Gernot Hassknecht ging es mir auch als
ich im vergangenen Jahr die Diskussion
zur Aufteilung des co2-preises verfolgt
habe denn eigentlich gab es ja ein
Kompromiss der auf Regierungsseite
ausverhandelt wurde die SPD-Fraktion war
damit einverstanden sogar die ehemalige
Kanzlerin hatte zugestimmt nur die
Unionsfraktion blockierte dem Vorschlag
sie war der Ansicht das Mieterinnen und
Mieter die Kosten alleine tragen sollten
und das obwohl die gar keinen Einfluss
darauf haben welche Heizungen in ihrem
Keller steht oder wie gut Ihre Fenster
isoliert sind
denn das alles entscheiden die
vermietenden die den CO2-Preis in vollem
Umfang in den MieterInnen Mieter
weitergeben können
allein dieses verhindern langfristiger
Lösungen verzichtmieterinnen und Mieter
seitens der Union macht schon wütend
jetzt ein Jahr später schießen wir uns
in Folge von Putins Angriffskrieg gegen
die Ukraine die Preise zusätzlich in die
Höhe viele Menschen wissen gar nicht
mehr wie sie die nächsten Rechnungen
bezahlen sollen und obendrauf müssen die
Mieterinnen und Mieter in diesem Jahr
und auch noch die kompletten co2-kosten
alleine stemmen und all das weil die
Union lieber Politik zugunsten der
großen bauen wohnkonzerne gemacht hat
anstatt Millionen von Menschen
langfristig zu entlassen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
[Applaus]
und ich sage diese Klientelpolitik und
Ungerechtigkeit ist es die Menschen auch
an Politik zweifeln lässt und die Einweg
Gernot Hassknecht vollkommen zu Recht
zum Ausrasten bringt
wir werden dafür gewählt Lösungen zu
schaffen und zum Wohle aller Menschen zu
handeln und was die Unionsfraktion
damals blockiert hat werden wir jetzt
durchsetzen und so Millionen von
Menschen entlasten genau das ist
übrigens auch was wir als Ampel seit
Beginn der Krise konsequent in allen
Bereichen machen wie entlasten die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger und tun alles
dafür dass wir gemeinsam gut durch diese
schwierige Zeit kommen
was wir jetzt wollen ist ein faires
System in dem sich Mietende und
vermietende die co2-kosten aufteilen
denn beide Parteien können etwas dazu
beitragen dass weniger ausgestoßen wird
Mieterinnen und Mieter durch sparsames
heizen und die vermietenden durch
Sanierungsmaßnahmen an der Gebäudehülle
etwa oder durch den Einbau einer neuen
Heizung schon wieder Kollege föst auch
gesagt hatte schon kleine
sanierungsfortschritte werden durch das
Stufenmodell angereizt und belohnt und
genau das ist auch gut so Menschen die
ein Eigenheim besitzen rüsten seit
Anfang des Jahres so schnell um dass
mancher Wärmepumpenhersteller mit der
Produktion gar nicht mehr
hinterherkommen und solarinstallateure
bis ins nächste Jahr ausgebucht sind für
Mietshäuser hingegen ist der Anreiz
weniger ersichtlich die steigenden
Nebenkosten zahlen nämlich die die darin
wohnen das ist ungerecht für Menschen in
schlechtereierten Gebäuden die häufig
über ein kleines Einkommen verfügen
ich freue mich jetzt sehr darauf den
Gesetzentwurf weiter im
parlamentarischen Verfahren zu beraten
und wir werden sicherlich über ein oder
anderen Punkt noch mal sprechen ich bin
sehr sehr überzeugt dass ich mich mal am
Ende unserer Verhandlungen nicht wieder
aufregen muss denn Gegensatz zu Union
ist die Ampel in der Lage faire Lösung
zu finden unsere Schulen wir dann auch
den Blutdruck von Gernot herzlichen Dank
[Applaus]
der Kollege Dr Jan Mago lucolatet ist
das Wort für die cdu/csu-fraktion
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren lieber Kollege fist sie
wissen ja dass ich sie sehr schätze aber
mich wundert es schon ein bisschen
sozusagen welchen Sinneswandel jetzt die
hätten und als FDP-Fraktion ist immer
durchlaufen haben ich kann mich noch
sehr gut daran erinnern als wir die
Diskussion vor gut einem Jahr hatten wie
wir denn mit der Aufteilung der
co2-kosten umgehen da hat ihr Kollege
immerhin Fraktionsvize teurer gesagt man
dürfe bei diesem Vorschlag den von
Seiten der SPD kamen 50/50 aufzuteilen
man dürfe das Verursacher Prinzip nicht
auf den Kopf stellen man möge dieses
ideologische abkassieren der Vermieter
verhindern und das muss ich sagen das
finde ich jetzt schon bemerkenswert sie
haben ja in ihrer Rede jetzt auch gesagt
naja also fifty fifty das würden sie
irgendwie als ungerecht empfinden dann
frage ich mich aber schon wieso genau
dieser Vorschlag nämlich 50 50 Teilung
ohne irgendwelche sonstigen
Voraussetzungen an ihrem Vorschlag
zugrunde gelegt ist nicht bei den
Wohngebäuden aber ein Nichtwohngebäuden
das passt doch nicht zusammen das doch
völliger Quatsch was sie hier erzählt
Entschuldigung
wir sind uns noch völlig einig natürlich
wollen wir ein Gesetz haben wir wollen
ein Gesetz haben was dem Ziel dem
überragenden Ziel von Klimaschutz dient
und deswegen ist es ja auch richtig wir
müssen eine Lösung finden was dazu führt
dass Brennstoff eingespart wird das
weniger CO2 emittiert wird und dass wir
am Ende des 1,5 Grad Ziel erreichen aber
da muss man doch schon mal fragen
erreicht denn dieser Gesetzentwurf den
die Ampel hier uns vorliegt erreicht ihr
denn dieses Ziel hat er denn die
entsprechende Lenkungswirkung und da
muss man mal die beiden beteiligten sich
angucken also die Vermieter wir haben
hier drüber gesprochen die energetische
Sanierung da wollen sie einen Anreiz
setzen die spielt in nach diesem
Gesetzentwurf überhaupt gar keine Rolle
ob ich ein völlig grottig geschlechtet
saniertes gebäude habe was oder noch nie
angefasst worden ist oder ob ich ein
hocheffizientes Gebäude habe das Spiel
nach ihrem Gesetzentwurf überhaupt keine
Rolle so es kommt alleine darauf an es
kommt alleine darauf an welcher
Brennstoff imitiert wird und dann will
ich immer das an zwei Beispielen
festmachen nehmen Sie ein Haus ein
gleiches Haus haben die identischen
Nutzer aber sie haben unterschiedliche
Witterungsbedingungen mal einen kalten
Winter mal einen warmen Winter da wird
der Brennstoffverbrauch unterschiedlich
sein und weil der Brennstoffverbrauch
dann unterschiedlich sein wird haben Sie
einmal eine gute Klasse und einmal eine
schlechte Klasse ohne dass es
irgendwelche Unterschiede gibt oder
nehmen Sie zwei identische Häuser wo sie
die gleichen Witterungsbedingungen haben
aber unterschiedliche Nutzer einmal mit
Familien mit vielen Kindern einmal
Senioren wo wir alle miteinander wissen
die haben und die brauchen auch mehr
Wärme in der Wohnung die werden
sozusagen mehr heizen auch dann haben
sie wieder zwei unterschiedliche Klassen
von Häuser mit unterschiedlichen
Verteilungen und obwohl aus völlig
identisch ist vom sanierungszustand da
fehlt doch jede Logik bei ihrem
Vorschlag das ist doch nicht gerecht
und das gleiche und das gleiche gilt
auch für die Mieterseite wir sind es
doch alle einig das Verbrauchsverhalten
von Mieterinnen und Mietern spielt eine
ganz entscheidende Rolle an dieser
Stelle aber jetzt gucken sich doch mal
an wenn Sie Mieterinnen und Mieter haben
die einen eher großzügiges und nicht zu
sagen verschwenderisches
Nutzungsverhalten haben das führt am
Ende dazu dass ein Haus in eine
schlechte Klasse eingruppiert werden
kann weil eben sehr viel Brennstoff
verbrauchte war die Heizung
hochgeschraubt wird das führt dann aber
dazu wegen der schlechten klasse dass am
Ende die Kosten für die Mieterinnen und
Mieter reduziert werden weil dann
sozusagen die Aufteilung zulasten des
Vermieters ist und umgekehrt um das mal
positiv zu wenden die Mieterinnen und
Mieter die machen was wir wollen die
bewusst sind klimabewusst sind Ihre
Heizung ein Stück runter drehen und
sozusagen Verzicht üben das führt dann
dazu dass ein solchesaus in eine bessere
Klasse einsortiert wird mit der Folge
dass diese Miete und Mieter die sparsam
gewesen ist am Ende höhere kostentagen
müssen das ist doch absurd das ist
völlig kontraproduktiv was sie hier
vorschlagen
und nicht zuletzt ich habe sie gerade
schon angepasst was sind denn am Ende
die Auswirkungen von diesem Gesetz
diejenigen die Senioren die älteren
Menschen unser Land die Familie mit
kleinen hindern die gezwungen sind ihre
Heizung ein Stück weit höher zu drehen
weil eben kleinere Kinder es wärmer
haben müssen weil Senioren es wärmer
haben müssen die werden doch auf dem
Wohnungsmarkt zukünftig noch viel mehr
Probleme haben eine Wohnung zu finden
weil alle Vermieter natürlich sagen wenn
die bei mir einziehen die verbrauchen
viel Energie viel CO2 Kosten ich muss ja
am Ende tragen dann nehme ich doch
lieber den Berufstätigen Single der im
Fitnessstudio durch der ist nie zu Hause
der verbraucht keine Kosten das ist
sozialpolitisch völlig verfehlt was Sie
uns hier vorschlagen an der Stelle
und wenn man wenn man darüber kann man
ja auch diskutieren ob so eine
co2-kostenumlage angesichts der ohnehin
schon galoppierenden Preise bei
überhaupt noch notwendig ist um
lenkungswirkungen zu entfalten um
Menschen zu sparsam Verhalten anzuheben
wenn das wenn man sagt man will das
trotzdem dann muss es aber noch ein
einfaches ein bürokratiearmes Modell
sein was mit einer echten
Lenkungswirkung versehen ist was genau
an dem energetischen Zustand fest macht
da müssen wir wenn wir das wollen hin
wir brauchen eine verlässliche und
auskömmliche Förderung dass das
angereizt wird für Vermieter und
Vermieter zu investieren in ihnen
Gebäude bestanden so da können wir dann
drüber reden da können wir auch
möglicherweise im parlamentarischen
Verfahren darüber reden allerdings will
ich dann schon sagen ihr Gesetz ist vom
Ansatz her so falsch konstruiert das ist
wie beim Hemd wenn man das von anfängt
falsch zu knöpfen dann wird man das oben
auch nicht mehr gerade kriegen und
deswegen nutzt auch ein
parlamentarisches Verfahren hier an der
Stelle nicht ziehen Sie lieber im
Gesetzentwurf zurück und präsentieren
Sie uns was ordentliches dann können wir
auch miteinander ins Gespräch kommen
vielen Dank
war das für die CDU CSU-Fraktion so
nächster Redner nächste Rednerin in dem
Fall für die Fraktion Bündnis 90 grün
wird jetzt sein Lisa badum sie ist die
Obfrau im Ausschuss für Klimaschutz und
Energie
[Applaus]
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen Kollegen Herr lucczak ich
bin wirklich verwirrt also ich habe ihre
Rede nicht verstanden lesen Sie einfach
das Gesetz noch mal durch es geht
tatsächlich darum
Lenkungswirkung bei den Vermietern und
Vermietern zu erzeugen für Wärmedämmung
und für erneuerbare Energiequellen das
ist das Ziel des Gesetzes zum Thema
Energieverbrauch möchte ich Ihnen noch
sagen wir reden heute nur über die
Aufteilung des co2-preises die
Energiekosten tragen die MieterInnen
Mieter weiterhin das wird ja von ihnen
unterschlagen das heißt ich merke
selbstverständlich als Mieter Mieterin
wenn ich mehr Energie verbrauche und
dieses Bild von dem kettenrauchen den
Mieter der stundenlang in Unterhemd am
Fenster hängt an der gluckernden heißen
Heizungen oder jemand der in Unterhemd
sich in die heiße Wohnung setzt
Entschuldigung also das ist ein Bild von
Mieterinnen und Mietern was was hier auf
40 Millionen Menschen in Deutschland
beziehen ist es einfach populistisch und
das werden wir nicht akzeptieren bitte
steigen Sie in die sachdebatte ein es
ist doch klar es ist doch klar wer in
gut gedämmten Häusern wohnt ja der muss
sich diesen Winter etwas weniger Sorgen
machen bei dieser Energiekrise die wir
haben das Problem ist leider nur durch
die sehr geringe Sanierungsrate im
letzten Jahren von einem Prozent haben
dieses Privileg nur wenige Auserwählte
in diesem Land in der Masse heizt
Deutschland weiter auf die Straße hinaus
das ist die traurige Wahrheit und ich
muss die 16 Jahre Merkel jetzt leider
noch mal anbringen ja es ist so und
warum stehen wir an diesem Punkt weil
nach 16 Jahren merke sie hat 1997 das
erste mal angekündigt nach 16 Jahren
wurde die co2-bepreisung Gebäudebereich
eingeführt und auch die ergänzenden
Instrumente ja wie das Thema eben
wirklich gezielte Förderung von
Sanierung mit hohen Standards von
Wärmepumpen Solarthermie PV auch das ist
über die letzten Jahre liegen gelassen
worden wäre in den letzten Jahren
wirklich spürbar Klimaschutz in den
Gebäuden betrieben worden wir reden hier
von ein Drittel des CO2 Verbrauches dann
bräuchten wir die co2-bepreisung nicht
aber so ist es eben nicht gekommen das
sind die Fakten und deswegen brauchen
wir weiter den CO2-Preis als planbares
klimaschutzinstrument wir haben jetzt
einen schockartigen Anstieg von fossilen
Preisen in diesem Jahr wir müssen auch
mittellangfristig die nächsten Jahre
planen wie wir unsere Gesellschaft
transformieren und deswegen ist dieses
Instrument so wichtig und notwendig und
die Vermieterinnen und Vermieter die
eben dämmen die erneuerbare Wärmequellen
hineinnehmen die wollen wir belohnen von
daher macht es einfach keinen Sinn dass
die Mieterinnen und Mieter das sind eben
wirklich die Hälfte aller
Bundespräsidenten Bundes diesen
CO2-Preis weiter allein zahlen
daher ist dieses Gesetz überfällig ist
leider auch ein ja wir müssen es aus der
letzten Legislatur übernehmen müssen ist
jetzt machen und ich freue mich auch
sehr auf die Beratungen wir Grüne hätten
uns auch ein anderes noch einfaches
Modell vorstellen können dass die
Vermieter 100% der Kosten übernehmen das
wäre noch simpler gewesen wir können uns
mit dem Stufenmodell anfreunden haben
wir haben
einige nachbesserungsbedarfe es ist zum
Beispiel wichtig dass auch die
MieterInnen Mieter die an der Fernwärme
hängen mit einbezogen werden ich freue
mich auf eine konstruktive Zeit und eine
gute verabschiedungsgesetzes am Ende
dankeschön
ja sagt hier Elisa badum für
die Grünen Fraktion
bei den Menschen die hier Dienst tun für
uns wenn zu viel Zeit überzogen wird
deswegen meine herzliche Bitte für die
ist auch dann nach den anstrengenden
sitzungszeiten mal Feierabend nicht für
uns wir haben wir arbeiten ja weiter
aber die Menschen die hier rund um uns
herum Arbeiten deswegen bin ich ein
bisschen lauter bei dem abbrechen und
jetzt hat der Kollege Andreas mit Ritter
das Wort für die SPD-Fraktion auf die
Redezeiten geachtet und auch auf die
gesamte debattenlänge von der
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin letzter Redner
zu diesem Tagesordnungspunkt Andreas
metretter für die SPD Unternehmen die
Heizöl oder Erdgas auf in den Markt
bringen dafür ein CO2-Preis und mit dem
brennstoffemissions-emissionen von
Gebäuden einen Preis bekommen
trotzdem hat der Gebäudesektor im
letzten Jahr die erlaubte
jahresemissionsmenge um 2 Millionen
Tonnen co2-equivalente überschütten das
liegt sicher nicht allein aber schon
auch an einem Design-Fehler des
co2-preises sowie der CO2-Preis im
Gebäudesektor jetzt ausgestaltet ist
kann er eben keinen Anreiz für die
Sanierung von Gebäuden sein weil die den
CO2-Preis zahlen die Mieten denn
Investitionsentscheidungen treffen die
vermiedenen das passt nicht das ist
wieder zielführend noch fair das wollen
wir ändern deswegen setzen wir jetzt das
um was wir im Koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart haben mit diesem Stufenmodell
sorgen wir dafür dass der CO2-Preis
endlich seine Lenkungswirkung auch
wirklich entfalten kann wir sorgen dafür
dass der CO2-Preis bei den richtigen
ankommt
sind Wohnungen gut saniert dann setzen
wir ein Anreiz für ein energiesparendes
Heizverhalten weil die mieteren Mieter
dann den Großteil der co2-kosten tragen
das ist klimapolitisch auf jeden Fall
richtig genauso wichtig ist es aber auch
in schlecht sanierten Wohnungen den
Anreiz darauf zu setzen dass die Gebäude
endlich auf Stand gebracht werden und
deshalb zahlen in solchen Fällen die
Vermieterinnen und Vermieter den großen
Teil den Großteil der CO2 Kosten
damit kann der CO2-Preis seine
Produktion auch wirklich erfüllen es
wird dann für Vermieterinnen und
Vermieter eben finanziell attraktiver
dass sie sich um eine neue Heizung oder
bessere Dämmung in ihren Gebäuden
kümmern und genauso soll der CO2-Preis
ja in allen Bereichen wirken übrigens
haben die vermietenden ja damit nicht
nur ein Einfluss auf die co2-kosten
sondern insgesamt auf die Heizkosten
ihrer Mieterinnen und Mieter auch wenn
es in der Debatte hier auch oft anders
dargestellt wird
sanierungsstaub bedeutet eben auch dass
die mietenden zu viel fürs Heizen zahlen
müssen und das hat auch eine große
sozialpolitische Dimension in den
zugigen Buden wohnen eben nicht die
Menschen die ihre Wohnung Überheizen da
wohnen die die sich schon längst einen
zweiten Pulli angezogen haben weil sie
sich die Heizkosten gar nicht leisten
können und genau deswegen machen wir
dieses Gesetz doch Frau Lötsch
meine Damen und Herren wenn wir die
Energiewende schaffen wollen dann müssen
wir endlich bei der energetischen
Sanierung und bei der Modernisierung von
Heizungen ein Zahn zulegen der Preis
führt CO2 kann nur wirken wenn er bei
den richtigen ansetzt dann ist ein
wichtiger Baustein auch für die
wärmewende und genau dafür sorgen wir
mit diesem Gesetz
Andreas Mehltretter für die SPD hatte
hier das letzte Wort in dieser Debatte
ja der Gesetzentwurf der Bundesregierung
zum Kohlendioxid Kosten
aufteilungsgesetz der geht jetzt in die
Beratung in die parlamentarischen das
Gesetz soll dann wenn es dann durch
Bundestag und Bundesrat ist ab dem
ersten Januar 2023 in Kraft treten